i'm a 24 year old graphic designer from
grace
i'm suffering from a form of
self-destructive ocd for the last 15
years of my life
meaning that i overthink everything
about my profession too many times to
the point that i'm never satisfied with
my work
oh my god now often i'm really harsh on
myself and my results
even though i've been working in the
industry since i was 21 for the likes of
nike
hugo boss and other companies my design
pieces get a lot of attention both in
the public and professional circles but
that doesn't seem to help me relax or
settle down to find my personal serenity
i heard so many times on your podcast
about bobby always being tough on
himself even though he's one of the best
comedians out there
i always wondered how did he cope with
this self-doubt and how did he learn to
stand on his feet
do you have any advice on how to find
some self-love for myself listen
listen to me yeah the other day i drive
to burbank to do adr
for magnum pi i'm in this so when you do
adr
it's basically when you're shooting
something and
you know a plane flies by and they they
can't get a clean audio on something you
have to go back later
and do it in a studio so what they do is
you go into a sound studio
they have this gigantic screen out there
and you have
a sound engineer in another room and
they have either
what they call a um there's a streak
where the streak will come in and as
soon as it
matches you have to start talking right
and then you do three beats before you
talk so
boom right and i was watching myself
and i literally stopped everything and i
turned away because i also have the
producers on zoom
and i'm screaming oh that's what you
chose right i'm so critical of myself
right on how i look
who's the makeup it's like you know you
see [ __ ] liver spots on my face
on the screen right and you know and i'm
not
i do in a funny way where everyone's
laughing i don't do it in a
hostile negative way they love it right
because that's who i am but
there is you know a big it it really is
a very difficult thing
to look at because it's like i'm so
judgmental of myself
and i'm so harsh on myself and um
and there are times where i think how
the [ __ ] am i working
you know i really think that you know
and
what my therapist says is you know
let's look you have your inner dialogue
right but then you have reality
and let's just look at the facts and the
facts are
they keep asking you to do that show
right it was my seventh one right yeah i
just got a big movie and i don't talk
about it but in and then i'm going
i'm going to me in to hungary and me i
could say that
i'm going to hungary i'm doing a kind of
a blockbuster movie
i have small scenes in it but it's a
huge thing
and i send an audition right
they called me back and they said you
got the job right
these are factual things that are
actually happening right
and then you have this this this other
thing in my head that's happening
i mean and it's like i struggle between
the two things
but sometimes i just have to take a step
back and go
what's real right and the reality is
is that i'm working i'm getting work
and you know my perception of myself
should not be in play in fact
my therapist said i can't do this
anymore which is what i do is
after a scene i do this every time after
a scene think okay we're moving on
you know in show business they never go
the director never goes
after they do a scene they never walk up
to you and they go great job
they don't do anything they go like this
all right we're moving on let's go
and then you're like left there right
and so what i do is what i used to do is
i used to after
everything just kind of hang out at
video village video village is where
the director and sometimes an editor and
a producer is there and they're looking
at all
when you're doing it you know i mean
sometimes i hang out there
with my hands in my pocket just so that
i can find some little inkling of how i
did
right or sometimes i'll go to an actor
and i'll go
that was pretty good it was okay right
and to try to
fish for some sort of you know
acknowledgement
or and i'm not allowed to do that
anymore
you know my therapist says as soon as
you're done with your scene
you don't ask you just go home right
because it has nothing to do with you
because if they're moving on
they have it right so it's like there's
these little things that i because i'm
so
sensitive and i and i and i want that
[ __ ] acknowledgement or
some sort of verbal you know cue then
i'm doing
fine and at the end of the day it just
feeds into
you i mean that part of myself that i
don't want to give any energy or food to
you know yeah i was watching and this is
so
cheesy but i was watching american idol
what's up what oh so cold here i know me
too it's cold there
it's there's something i'm sweating yeah
yeah i am
and i was a good contestant she did a
very good job and
and and uh kate katy perry
asked her where do you gig i don't get
because
i get nervous i like i freak out even
when i'm singing from my parents
and my family because i just get so
nervous you know and
i want to fail and then lionel richie
says and this is something that
i'd heard years ago and i don't know why
it just you know
rehearing it struck a chord with me and
lionel richie goes
life begins at the
end of your comfort zone edge edge
i mean at the edge of sorry at the edge
of your comfort zone
and um all those moments where i'm the
only reason i corrected him by the way
is because he used this on me last
week when i was feeling really down i
used lionel richie
because i actually watched that episode
with him when lionel said that
and when i was having a meltdown last
week he was like sweetie i want i want
to say one thing to you
because this is why i'm so proud of you
he's like
you know so and so edge of your comfort
zone and in my head i was like
he just took that from lion though yeah
yeah but i did appreciate it
and for reminding but but but but let me
talk about that though
it's like there's a lot of like there's
a lot of
things where like the other day i put in
a audition for a movie
that i didn't get you're right but i
remember putting it in
sending it and then i remember i was
pacing around the bedroom yeah
and kalila goes you did it you
mean and you did the best you could it
looks good
you mean i didn't even need to say that
i didn't
you because that's that's our new thing
i'm not allowed to give you right right
right um is it bad or is it good
comments anymore yeah feedback
no feedback it's kind of like you did it
that was the best you could do
but you know i send it in and
but the but but the notes on it was good
like people
liked it they just it wasn't right for
the party so i wouldn't have let him
send it in if it wasn't good
do you know what i mean yeah yeah and i
knew that she hadn't seen it so um
my point is is that um
um those feeling like i'm nervous about
may
i really am i think about it a lot i go
you know the last
big movie i was in was the dictator
which you know in terms of
when you show up on a set and you go oh
my god there's like real like when i
the first day i shot on the dictator i
was in a makeup trailer with
ben kingsley anna ferris ed norton
and sasha baron cohen yeah it's crazy
and i was at the end
and they were in a row in the same
trailer and i remember going
what are you doing here in my mind you
don't belong here
that's my voice that's my inner voice
that's what it sounds like you son of a
bigger piece of [ __ ]
and so you know i'm nervous about it but
um
you know what i'm gonna go in
do the best i can and
even if i'm nervous i'm gonna write
through it
and overcome it and i'm going to rise to
the occasion
right and and if i don't and i fail
that's okay too that's okay too
so um but here's the one thing that's
the most important i'm gonna do it
you know a lot of people go i'm too
scared or
i'm not gonna try or all that kind of
stuff the one thing about me that i have
to
say that i love about myself is is that
even though i hate myself and even
though this is even through stand-up
right
when i was 23 when i started doing
stand-up and i think that was a piece of
[ __ ] and all that negative [ __ ] that's
in my head right
the one thing that i know about myself
is that i'll do it anyway
year i'm in and i'll try my best yeah
that's what i was going to say that's
the best
guy it's like no matter if you
have like the most desired outcome or if
you feel like you fail
you're going to keep doing it anyways
right because you've been doing it since
you're 20
you've been 20 since you were 21 years
old yeah so it doesn't look like you're
quitting anytime soon
it sounds like you have a passion for
doing this because you work so hard at
it
so it's like no matter the outcome
you've already chosen that path
so just let go of all the other noise
let go of all the other [ __ ]
like they say in a.a let go and let god
because like self-flagellation
i thought was like the most interesting
part about me
like where i was like is how you say it
george no no just like
interesting that that was the most
interesting part about you i thought
that i was like i'm so hard on myself
like the whole perfectionism thing
like i thought that was the most
interesting part about myself because
it's what kept me in line and being this
like
do-gooder and succeeding you know what i
mean like being an athlete
it's it's just i realized soon after
that it was
the number one reason why i was
suffering for so long
it was the number one thing that was
holding me back from actually
living out my dreams and putting pen to
paper and just having some sense of like
you know self-worth and and all of that
so it's like stop flogging yourself it's
just it's not cute anymore
it's not it's also not worth it and it's
also exhausting and it just doesn't do
anyone
any good can i share an aphorism my
favorite professor
thanks for listening please yes nick he
always said like perfect is the enemy of
good
and it's one of those things where if
you like think about it like yeah if
you're looking seeking perfection then
you never do anything
that's good because you're too busy
trying to be perfect all right
anyway that's a good one hey man
hey this is a great producer yeah